this week on forward jules and i discuss
homelessness billionaires performative
politics and much more join us this week
on forward
[Music]
and we are back welcome back jules how
are you i'm good how are you doing i
heard you left the country for the first
time in your life recently yeah 24 years
old left the country for the first time
in my life um grew up going to vacation
like florida basically and haven't taken
a vacation the past i'd say two and a
half years sure a lot of people same
boat yeah and so it was
i'm such a workaholic so it was kind of
hard to step away but it was like super
refreshing just reminded me that
solitude is important for everyone and
taking a break is definitely important
for everyone it helps you in the long
term be better so yes you heard it here
even
young world-class social media
influencers like jewels need to take a
break
get some detox
yeah it's like such a toxic work culture
today especially with work from homes
like i mean i love work from home i i
i'm kind of like a squirrel in a lot of
like situations in college i studied in
a library so it's like anyway work from
home it's even harder to shut down work
everyone knows that yep yeah it was a
good forced time to unplug um and really
rejuvenating because i think you think
when you go on vacation you're like oh
i'm gonna miss out on so much like time
and energy i could be putting into work
but i'm like okay now i can come back
like stronger and better with a
refreshed mind just recently it might be
a bit more
inspired balanced productive et cetera
et cetera i mean a lot of times breaks
the most productive things you can do
it's hard to do so i've been a ceo of a
number of organizations and there was
one company where
i would tell people to take vacation
they would not and then someone came to
me and said hey andrew the only way
people are going to take vacation around
here is if you take vacation so you
should take a vacation and i was like
okay it's not what you say it's what you
do so then i took a vacation and really
enjoyed the heck out of it
so make sure you get your break this
summer people i'd say two things that
are massive
kickstarters to your feeling
uh actually separated from from work uh
number one is travel in a change of
setting yep super helpful and the second
thing is nature which can be related to
travel but sometimes you know you can
just get some nature near you it's hard
to touch grass today sometimes so many
screens in front of your face yeah touch
that grass there's a meme that i think a
lot of people have seen that i i think
is hysterical but there's like a person
in a waterfall happy
and then
the language is like this poor schmuck
doesn't have a smartphone and doesn't
know why he should be miserable
which is pretty apt because
uh you know
we all check that phone and then see
like uh yeah the sticking feeling ugh so
i was on the road last week i was in
portland oregon which i have been to a
number of times thank you portland for
hosting me it was great endorsing a
gubernatorial candidate there betsy
johnson who i got together with awesome
while i was there she's an independent
imagine an independent winning uh
governor seat in oregon uh you know i
would love to help
see that happen
and so if you're in oregon check out
betsy johnson if you're not in oregon
and you like the idea of an independent
uh winning a governor's seat
she's a true
reach across the aisle problem solver
get things done very practical very
pragmatic that sort
so got together with betsy when i was in
oregon but one of the problems that
oregon was struggling with was
homelessness at least certainly in
portland there's a city center
and the uber driver you know you get
information from mover drivers but they
were like hey you know watch out
downtown portland and then talk to
people
and when i went into portland yes there
were some tents on sidewalks and and uh
the rest of it when you think about
homelessness as a problem right now in
america what city do you think of first
jewels um i hear san francisco a lot in
the news lately but also just like new
york kind of you know our major cities
the the big three i think of are san
francisco new york and la yep but then
being in portland i was like wow it's a
significant problem important like a
very significant issue and when's the
last time you were there the last time i
was in portland was when i was running
for president and it was approximately
2019. so i did a rally there thank you
again portland it was a lot of fun but
it got me reflecting on why homelessness
is such a pressing issue in these cities
and how people are responding how
government is and is not responding one
of the common things about those four
cities but i'm going to say this
phenomenon extends to you know i'm sure
like another half dozen dozen cities
yeah for sure around the country is that
they're all
in blue
cities uh they're all very very
democratic
uh and so it got me reflecting on what
the commonalities were and it also had
me
thinking about an article that came out
last week by nelly bowles about why is
san francisco a failed city uh it's an
article in the atlantic have you read
that article um i just went through it i
got through about two-thirds of it and
it is really good i highly suggest
people it depicts the picture paints it
really really well about what's going on
there as someone who lived there for
years and recently moved out of the city
so yeah so when i was talking to people
in portland they said that there's
something they call the homeless
in industrial complex you can throw
industrial complex on anything and it's
a pretty good description but they talk
about is there a bunch of nonprofits and
service organizations and government
agencies that are meant to ease the
homelessness problem
but somehow there are still lots of
homeless people and the resources don't
seem to be diminishing the issue
so people are voting with their feet and
in the case of portland that means
people leaving the city proper and
heading
in some cases to suburbs in some cases
just out of state entirely yep and i
thought to myself wow that totally
is happening
in san francisco in new york
and the netley bulls article talks about
the fact that there are these liberals
or progressives or democrats in office
that she says are larping values of
compassion while people are dying on the
street in front of us and i thought that
was maybe the strongest language i'd
seen applied so larping if you don't
know do you are you a geek jules you
know what larping is i don't i was just
gonna ask i'm not sorry not a geek
but but this this is a really
interesting critique because uh it's
live-action role-playing
um and so
right now in american life it is much
easier
to
express values than to live them oh okay
and one of the toughest things is that
at this point communication is
demonstration
so in the old days if i had compassion
for someone
maybe i would help them yeah
today
i would put out a social media post
saying uh oh i really care about this
group or i should help them so basically
virtue signaling yeah essentially it's
like expression has replaced action
right yes and and expression has
replaced action among our political
class
well the main thing that they'll say and
unfortunately this goes back to the
homeless industrial complex is we're
going to spend 10 50 100 million dollars
on helping the homeless
and so then you have these political
conversations around like are you
spending enough are you spending too
little uh the problem though is that no
one ever knows whether the money is
being spent effectively yep and here in
new york city the
direct expense around the homeless
population
is
something like 58 000
per person per year plus or minus
higher than like average salaries in
many areas all right now even for you as
a young person you hear that number and
you must think you know just think about
how much you pay for rent yep yep yeah
so so
so we're paying
in each of these cities
half a dozen to a dozen
agencies let's call it 30 40 50 000
ahead but
it's not often the case that that money
is just being spent directly
on
rent for the person you just you know
and a lot of these people are struggling
with
mental health issues and
so what is it being spent on for them
well it's being spent on teams
of
workers
uh it's being spent on support services
that may or may not be
uh utilized yep and so there's a story
in the nelly bulls article about someone
calling the cops because there's a
mentally ill homeless person having an
episode
and is naked and eating a cardboard box
apparently
and then the cops come and say hey
there's nothing i can do because
not
threatening anyone even if i were to
arrest them they'd be on the street in a
matter of hours so you know carry on
more or less when they were looking to
get them off the street in this story a
homeless activist came up and said hey
to the homeless person you do not have
to go with this
um officer if you don't want to like
that there's almost
an excessive
deference to the individual
even though in some cases the individual
is mentally ill or in distress or
whatnot
and
the
language that nellie uses in this
article in the atlantic
is
by pretending to be compassionate about
these people we're just watching them
literally die in front of us yeah well
in the article i think they were talking
about like even the language people use
to describe homeless people they don't
like to say homeless people they like to
say people who are experiencing
homelessness in san francisco like
you're saying that just like
linguistics of it all but yeah you're
watching them die on the corner of the
street when you could but it's much more
important how we describe that than what
we actually do
you know when i got into i mean i think
most people completely understood what i
was saying but when i was running for
mayor of new york city i said look you
know homeless people have rights you
know i also have rights like people and
families walk in the streets who don't
want to be
attacked and i said this in reference to
a mom
friend in our neighborhood uh in
manhattan who was punched in the face by
a homeless person and saying like you
know like that mom has rights too not to
get attacked and i was attacked for this
because it seemed like i was somehow not
mindful or compassionate or respectable
enough of people who are struggling with
mental health issues which i think most
people understood completely that like
these things
uh are not
uh a dichotomy where you can have
compassion for the person who's
struggling with an episode on the street
and also have compassion for
the mom who's going to get punched or
the person who's
you know going to be
attacked or victimized in some way and
in most of these cases
people are going to do what the families
in portland are doing what the families
in san francisco are doing for sure uh
which just leave
you know you're there and you're like
okay
if the public sector is failing in terms
of providing these people services
uh why am i here you know and in each of
these instances
they're often paying a premium to be
there because these are expensive
locations so then they think i'm just
going to trade it in for a house in the
suburbs so that these bureaucratic
failures in democratic
uh jurisdictions
are driving people out in various ways
and the problem is that everyone's
trying to frame it as an ideological
argument rather than
whether it's effective practical solving
the problem
in this case getting
thousands of people who are struggling
with homelessness
off the streets into better environments
where they can actually get some care
and now a word from our sponsor better
help even though it's the summer time
you can still get under a dark cloud you
can still be anxious
stressed irritable
sometimes you snap at people you know
it's not them it's you
better help online therapy wants to
remind you to prioritize yourself
better help is customized online therapy
that offers video phone even live chat
sessions with your therapist so you
don't have to see anyone on camera if
you don't want to it's much more
affordable than in-person therapy and
you can be matched with a therapist in
under 48 hours our listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
yang that's better h-e-l-p-com
yang take charge of your mental health
you'll be glad you did and so will your
loved ones betterhelp.com
yang
[Music]
i'm trying to understand like the
political mindset here aside from you
know you know funding these non-profits
and everything what are the maybe
political or societal incentives that uh
these democrats are looking at in terms
of not providing housing
and instead doing like yeah these
services that you're saying might not be
utilized like what are like these incent
like the incentives that they're pushing
against almost
well uh so and this is another thing too
that like i talk to homeless people and
they don't want to they do not want to
go into the shelters right here in new
york city because if you go into the
shelters one of them just called it hell
because you're cohabiting with people
who are having episodes and are violent
melania so they just talk about getting
attacked okay and so you look at that
and say well it's understandable so so
then you need an alternate set of
accommodations for them which in new
york city one of the more successful
efforts was around something called safe
haven beds where churches and
non-profits and religious organizations
had beds available that
often were solitary
which is the major thing but when you
ask about the politics of it and this is
one reason why uh universal basic income
i thought was such an important idea in
the presidential
was that and again that is not the case
that you know like not every mentally
ill homeless person is just like hey you
give them cash and like problem solved
but there is some subset of them that
you could give them cash and it'd be
problem solved or you could put cash in
the hands of people who are in the
precipice of homelessness before they
become homeless
and you would end up um solving the
problem
the the the fundamental problem is that
we spend money on organizations uh that
are meant to solve a problem but then
the incentive of the organization is to
uh provide jobs and compensation and
resources
for the organization itself and then no
one wants to go in and be like hey i'm
gonna get rid of this organization
because problem solved yeah yeah so so
you mean it's a very very rare
organization that will put itself out of
business
you know and so if you show up on the
scene and be like hey turns out that you
know best way to solve this problem is
for you to fire all of us and just like
give the resources to the
uh the direct recipients you know like
no organization is going to come out and
do this it's one reason why
direct cash transfers in the
international giving space
such an awesome powerful idea but it's a
massive innovation there's an
organization called give directly that
got started not that long ago which by
the way ended up showing that like it's
not uh nets or
books uh well nets are pretty good
that's saved a lot of lives but
or cows or because they're all these
ngos that in theory were like hey we're
gonna give these people what they want
uh or need
and then it turned out that you know
a lot of the resources never reach the
recipients there's a lot of like
corruption a lot of bureaucracy and so
give directly said let's skip it and
just like give the money directly to
people and the results were much much
better
and what they were trying to show folks
is like look would you rather give two
million dollars that to help indigent uh
villagers in africa to buy them stuff
that frankly they don't need like you go
there and there'd be like laptops
gathering dust being used as
paperweights which also is you know real
thing
like you pretty much you imagine that
these are the things that the people
need and so you get some donors to give
you money and then it goes into these
things and then are those actually what
people needed
sometimes yes sometimes no but the
studies clearly showed that
small cash grants were much much more
effective at solving the problems of the
these folks and the same thing's playing
out here
in the us in different ways where we're
spending money really ineffectively on
these
bureaucracies and organizations that
often are just self-perpetuating and
then people look up and say hey what's
the problem it's like oh they must not
have enough money let's like put some
more money into it
and the accountability is absent because
if you don't solve the homelessness
problem what actually happens is just
people leave your tax base goes down
but
nothing happens to the folks in power
most of the time because it's a
one-party system and you're like well
you know like what are you gonna do
really so what what's happening in san
francisco right now is almost unheard of
where they actually recalled three board
member school board members over you
know slightly related issue
and the
uh d.a you know someone who openly said
look i'm not going to
prosecute
offenses up to a certain level i think
it was like a thousand bucks um when i
was in san francisco
a few months ago
a walmart no walgreens was robbed in
front of me okay uh and then the
another person just looked at me and
said just shrugged and said like san
francisco yeah and then maybe a week
later they closed that walgreens along
with a bunch of others in walgreen's
band announcement saying we're closing
seven walgreens um because among other
things they keep getting robbed so
so you're you're and so this district
attorney got recalled very very recently
and it's very very unusual for that to
happen
where things got so bad and nasty that a
group of citizens arose and said
we're going to get rid of you and it won
by 20 points
and you saw a real switch in attitude
from the very liberal mayor of san
francisco 2 where for a while she was
like hey let's be humane and treat
people with respect to dignity or
rhetoric switched where she was like
let's take our city back this is
unacceptable uh and having been in san
francisco i mean the stuff you see there
will blow your mind
like the the the level of
uh human misery
and decay and i've been doing
this sort of work for i suppose for
you know over a decade and the the
sharpest experiences i had with urban
ruin and decay
were in detroit in 2011 and 2012. around
when they declared bankruptcy by the way
i mean detroit at that era
bad very very bad and i remember
visiting detroit in 2011
in a rental car ceiling the airport
driving town when i was in my rental car
and i was at a traffic light i was red
red light i was alone and i really
really wanted to run that red light
and i wanted to run that red light
because there were some vagrants
on the outside of my car gotcha they
did not seem like in their their right
minds and like it i like could have just
easily imagined them just like you know
yep step in front of the car but like it
was a red light and i was like oh [ __ ]
do i run this thing so there were a
number of things so number one was the
vagrance number two is the fact that uh
there were very very few cars in the
road so it did not feel like anyone was
going to be adversely impacted by my
running this red there's like very very
minimal traffic yep and number three
uh it seemed like there was very very
minimal law enforcement
[Laughter]
yeah if no one's on the road and that
that's a possible situation you're in
it's like okay yeah let me run through
this
yeah yeah so so like it was like a real
act of will for me not not to run the
red light so for some backdrop detroit
was the most extreme example during this
time in part because its population had
dropped from about 1.7 million at the
peak in the uh let's call it 80s to
around 600 000 at this time so you're
talking about a city that was like 60
percent
empty slash abandoned so you'd look
around and there were just like
swabs of
you know derelict buildings and
husks in certain places and it really
does
mess with you
but even more than the buildings it was
like the the sense of
frankly derelict human beings so when
you're in an environment like that um
like it there's a certain sense that
you get it's it's unease it's not a good
feeling you're like okay you know that
this is
potentially like you know frankly unsafe
um and when i was in parts of downtown
san francisco you definitely feel that
there are people in their right mind not
in their right mind and drug addict
addicts and whatnot um and so you're
you're seeing these visible
evidence of
human failure that translates then into
public failure because in an ideal world
you think well someone should be helping
this person they should be in a hospital
somewhere they should be getting
treatment they shouldn't you know not be
killing themselves
uh on our streets
and
that that senses has spread to various
places uh and in portland it has given
rise to again this sort of discontent
with the democratic
party
and leadership a lot of frustration i
think that the two things that people
are turning on the democrats for are
evident in what happened in san
francisco which is homelessness slash
public safety slash crime like all in
one bucket and the other is schools
where these school board members hit and
this is another thing that people in
portland are super pissed off about
where their schools are underperforming
in various ways and then you go
and you say and so you know democrats
again in theory the education party in
new york city the amount that's being
spent
per school child in new york i think is
something around
maybe thirty thousand dollars ahead
so these are some of the numbers where
you're just like what i think nationwide
it's
i mean eighteen thousand nineteen
thousand so like when you look at the
numbers you know being early so where's
this money going what's happening
there's just a lot of frustration around
these dysfunctional bureaucracies and
the the problem is that you have a
two-party system in many of these
environments essentially a one-party
system so the incentives for the schools
to perform better or for these public
agencies or homelessness services to
perform better again they're like well
you know don't really need to do that
much and then you wind up with failing
urban cores
[Music]
and then doubling down on that is is the
new work from home
migration where
if you have a place like midtown
manhattan
i used to work in those office buildings
in my 20s it was like uh did you ever
work in that neighborhood in those
buildings no no i i used to work at a
wee work but
where was it we were it was times square
area so close to here oh actually i know
that we've i've been there
so i was in my late 20s working at this
startup in the you know rent a hq place
but it was in a fancy office building so
i would go to park avenue every day for
my job not every day but you know
whenever i was around and we were in the
office and so i remember that
neighborhood i remember all of the
office denizens who worked in the
neighborhood because that's where we all
so i would see
like that people going to you know
whatever it is citibank law firm
excellent like we were all like hanging
out in that neighborhood and and today
uh and oh by the way you know like the
business lunch crowd was so
popping where you'd go out like everyone
was getting lunch the same time of day
and all of the eateries there was
brimming with yuppies
and i was like this you know at that
point my startup had failed another
startup it kind of failed like i was
throwing parties at night and then i and
so being part of this corporate office
culture
um it felt a little bit like i was
role-playing frankly because i was like
i didn't really see myself as like that
kind of person but it also felt like a
version of success
uh i suppose because that you know there
was like there were all these people in
suits going to
the office every day and that was sort
of like
like kind of one of them um
the uh and
now you go to those office buildings and
they're 80 vacant you go to one of those
lunch spots eighty percent
uh empty i mean actually i take it back
most of those lunch spots don't even
exist anymore no one's having dinner
there no one's having breakfast there
and so now that there is no business
lunch crowd
that establishment is shuttered like it
doesn't exist and the proportion of jobs
certainly in midtown that were provided
by the commuter crowd sky high so
so cities are getting hit by a double
whammy yep at a minimum um you know you
have these concerns about uh various
services particularly around
homelessness and public safety um and
the rest of it and then you have
uh all of the folks who used to be
commuting into that city now they're
just
zooming in or they you know they left uh
in some cases they left the entire metro
area that the portland visit made me
think wow this is happening
in more places than i'd realized it
might be happening in you know dozens of
cities around the country detroit in
2011 so i remember growing up i remember
the way san francisco was in the media a
lot now regarding homelessness i
remember like detroit was kind of a
focus in the media regarding
homelessness i'm not well versed in it
today has detroit
improved in that area i'm sure it's a
city so there's still issues but if so
if they have improved how did they go
about that detroit biola accounts has
gotten better
so i mean i i love the detroit story in
my book the war on normal people i go
through youngstown and camden and gary
and other places that had
de-industrialized
and then what happens to them with a
larger theme being like look when you
get rid of the jobs in an area uh crime
spikes and like you know mental illness
and ruin and decay and you know it's
like like after you lose the jobs it's
very hard to reconstitute for sure uh
these environments so detroit is the
most extreme example of that and uh i
became friends with a guy named dan
gilbert who owns the cleveland cavaliers
the way most people think of him but
he's in detroit not cleveland so he
invests billions of dollars of his own
money in downtown detroit quicken has a
giant building that he owned it was
actually one of the
wildest things that that
i had experienced in my career to that
point and i visit dan gilbert in his
office uh in
detroit and he has a model of downtown
detroit uh in his office it was like
either some like you know superhero
super villain type stuff and by the way
i love dan gilbert and the man is a
superhero in real life great family very
philanthropic like elsewhere by dan
gilbert really really great guy uh you
know
i'll stop there so he had but he had the
the this uh model of downtown detroit
and it was color-coded based upon
buildings that he already owned of which
there were any number and then buildings
that they were making offers on which or
there were any number
and then there were buildings that were
not theirs and then there were some
other other potential projects so it was
wild seeing this because it was an
individual who
so detroit at this point time it was
about to declare bankruptcy it had gone
through several like there was one very
very corrupt mayor who wound up in jail
so when someone looks at this
billionaire frankly like trying to
revive a city like you look at it and be
like oh you know that that's terrible
like having a private individual having
so much control over like you know my
community like you know like where where
have we gotten to i i'll tell you if dan
gilbert had not been there like you know
that place would be a wreck because he
went there when no one else wanted to go
there yep and invested like if he wasn't
there then like the entire thing is just
like desolate yeah um because you're
talking about a city that declares
bankruptcy gives you a sense of how bad
the services were at a certain point i
mean people were telling stories about
how you'd call 9-1-1 and it would be
you know
90 minutes or something you know like
some some very very long time frame so
this is when i was driving into the city
and visiting and then meeting with dan
and being like hey let's let's do great
stuff for detroit so since then there's
been more economic vitality
[Music]
in detroit uh more reinvestment i mean
there's still some problems but one of
the things that dan did and this is one
thing that i talked about in my
presidential campaign because it still
does piss me off so he did an inventory
of the blighted properties of detroit
because one of the problems is let's say
you're investing in the downtown core
which he was and then there are
you know there are other neighborhoods
but then there are blighted
neighborhoods that are total wrecks and
like fire traps and the rest of it yeah
so he priced out how much it would cost
to demo the blight
because you it's hard to demo blight you
know it's like you have to do it safely
and expensively and
environmentally responsibly and a bunch
of other things
so
i think they costed it out and it was
like 10 billion dollars to demo all the
blighted buildings of detroit which by
the way detroit's a beautiful physical
environment it's verdant uh you know
like their park on the island is
gorgeous
it was called the paris in the midwest
uh at one point because of its
architecture and it still has a ton of
beauty but when you go turn a particular
direction you will also see blighted
areas that you know like eat at you a
little bit yeah and so he was like hey
to get rid of all of these blighted
buildings cost about 10 billion dollars
which is by the way more than you know
any person
has to spend on demoing um these
buildings
and i mean detroit was literally
declaring bankruptcy at this time so
it's like you know where they're gonna
get 10 billion dollars i think you know
i think the state of michigan threw in
like a couple hundred million to you
know do some down this is a time too
when if you wanted to lay claim to a
property you could just have it if you
decide to pay for it and so when when i
was running for president i had this
idea of like the legion of builders and
destroyers because you literally need
it's like you have this country that's
falling apart its infrastructure is
decaying i'm all for rebuilding
infrastructure but you know we should be
demoing a lot of stuff
when you go to a lot of the country and
you see all these like empty husks of
buildings and whatnot i mean they really
give rise to
urban blight which depresses property
values in different ways and it does
spur crime uh in different ways we're
just really
terrible at
actually
[Music]
knocking stuff down and having it be an
environment that people could
uh live in or rebuild or or one now we
just kind of like let it languish it's a
very strange thing about
about the state so that's what i was
ticked off about that's a fascinating
point about him though because yeah a
headline saying a billionaire is you
know uh
taking in their hands to go about like
recovering detroit yeah people are like
oh billionaire all hands all hands off
this is terrible but it reminds me of
the tweet you made the other day it's
like i think you were talking about
congress i can't remember the tweet
exactly but you're talking about you
know your favorite people involved in
these things are people who have like
better things to do but they choose to
be doing this it's like oftentimes i've
talked about the incentives so we have
people who are have their lifelong
career in politics and so
it's just a weird situation in that way
always so this might as well i thought
you were talking about something else
but elon musk put out a tweet like a few
weeks ago being like who do you trust
more billionaires or politicians yep and
then people
voted billionaires i mean you know um it
could be biased
but then there there was this you know
like our our billionaires like evil for
being billionaires or whatnot and then i
put out there it's like look i tried to
make a be i said like billionaires are
human beings just like any others you
know there's some good ones some bad
ones and then i'd listed billionaires i
thought everyone liked just to be like
you know are you going to be mad at
oprah are you going to be mad at michael
jordan are you going to be mad at
richard branson are you going to be mad
because there's such a focus on like
literally just like five different
billionaires when there's what like
three thousand billionaires in the world
or something like i think there's like a
media focus specifically on like
a lot of big tech billionaires et cetera
that are yeah lebron just became a
billionaire so i was gonna hand lebron
the man started charter schools for
under privileged kids in ohio yeah he's
just really good at basketball it's like
you know lebron shouldn't be a
billionaire
so
so i thought you were
heading down that direction where it's
like oh there's a billionaire rebuilding
these cities but you're right too about
these political
lifers who are just clinging to it
because they're scared of doing anything
else i mean i think people know me well
enough to know
that if [ __ ] was humming in terms of
american politics and like our public
life like i would be thrilled to be
doing something else
i think people sense this about me so
like when someone and so this is the the
messed up time we are and i had in
america it's like okay systems are going
going poorly and then occasionally
someone will raise their hands and be
like hey i'm gonna do something about
this like um i'm a billionaire i'm gonna
spend 50 million dollars like uh on you
know a mayoral campaign um
that's making me think of this guy in
l.a who's running no i don't know
right now you have this fumbling system
that's like kind of creaking along and
like you know and failing us in various
ways unfortunately we're at a time where
having a billion dollars might be a pre
prerequisite to your being able to
compete
like
this
so like you know i i you know it's like
you look at it and being like like i i
guess like i i get how you'd like it if
just like a random moral person could
raise their hand and be like i'm gonna
you know do it i meet some of those
random moral people all the time who are
running for congress running for your
city council running for this like i
hate to tell you this but most of them
do not
get to a level where they're going to be
saving us anytime soon because our
system is so corrupt you know and i
recently put out a tweet that you know
like i got
asked about about how the democratic
party has become a lobbying firm with a
political party attached which i thought
was
fairly objectively accurate
you know you look at billionaires and be
like oh like you know like screw you for
going in and you know rebuilding the
city it's like you know without that
person that that was not happening and
like again there are some things that
certain
uh very wealthy individuals are doing
that i have a problem with like very
wealthy corporations but but it does
it's not intrinsically problematic if
someone who has a lot of resources that
decides to try and do something uh
positive
well on a personal growth scale on a
business scale it's like competition
fuels innovation and if you have a blue
state and talking about san francisco a
blue very blue city it's like there's
not a lot of
competition there and yeah with the
tubari system and so it's like
not even an independent in terms of a
political stance just an independent
entity coming in to be that um
sadly competition in a way of like
recovering homelessness
can be vital like this mayoral candidate
in l.a who's running against karen bass
who i hear really good things about
karen best but he's
coming and saying like look i'm a
manager like i'm going to clean up this
homelessness and
i confess to you all i find that
argument at least somewhat
compelling because it's like well you
know like do i trust someone who's been
in government
to
solve this problem given that it's a
problem in all of these different blue
cities and you know like you're more
likely to be someone who's going to like
shove money into a dysfunctional set of
agencies and then it continues to get
worse but like you're not really that
concerned about it because you can just
kind of glide over to your next election
maybe
you have like these people who are
climbing and falling within like this
this dysfunctional system whose
incentives aren't actually tied to
delivering or solving the problem
whereas i'm pretty confident that uh the
guy who's running on it who does not
have to be doing it like he's going to
do something
about it now
i mean i don't have a you know horse in
that particular race or anything but i
can see why it's going to work on a lot
of people because like more folks are
getting fed up
uh i'm getting fed up more people are
getting fed up with just like failing
institutions
and then no one really being held
accountable like the the san francisco
recalls of the d.a and the school board
members is really like a like a primal
scream i mean you know like that the
fact that
people who are frankly like rank and
file democrats for the most part decided
to stand up and be like all right enough
of this
nonsense i i have conversations with
people too it's like that there's like
this i've got you can imagine so i used
to be a democrat now i'm not and i go
around i'm building the forward party
and it's good fun like i talk to all
sorts of people who are ostensibly
democrats who are
just completely losing faith in the
party and uh
um leaving the party honestly i mean i
think the sweet spot for the forward
party is actually independents and
moderate republicans who look up and be
like hey this trump thing republican
party
like not
not what i signed up for
but more and more democrats whether they
go to ford or not are completely losing
faith in this thing so what do you think
is like
the kind of first step in terms of yeah
political in governments not talking
about these independent entities to
yeah within these non-profits you have
an incentive you want people to keep
their jobs but it's also yeah you need
that money to actually be going to the
problem at hand so what is the solution
there well so the the issue for a lot of
them is a change in policy and then a
change in political will
um where you look at someone and what i
was suggesting when i was running for
mayor was like look
um deferring to the person who might not
be in their right mind is like not the
right standard you know like there was a
point earlier where if someone was in
distress or unconscious or inebriated we
said like hey let's get them to to a bed
um and the single biggest thing is that
we don't have psych beds for these
people did you ever see a movie called
uh one flew over the cuckoo's nest
unfortunately not very sorry it was in
the 70s i barely saw it so what happened
was that there was a period of unwilling
in uh institutionalization and then a
movie called one flew of the cuckoo's
nest came out and essentially painted a
picture of it being totally inhumane to
institutionalize someone against their
will which i buy i mean it'd be terrible
to be institutionalized against your
will and like not people yeah the rest
of it so there was this massive shift
away from institutionalizing anyone
against their will and i think the
standard went so far now where it's
impossible to institutionalize anyone
that this is why homeless people are
dying on the street in san francisco
it's like oh can't do anything like what
you don't want to go can't go so the
institutions now are just kind of
circling the person being like well i
don't know what to do don't know what to
do um and we all know there's a medium
ground you know it's like look i'm not
going to grab people and like you know
like throw them in institutions yeah but
uh but i'm i think like taking you to a
place where you're going to be evaluated
and then if you do need
institutionalization there's an honest
to god place i can bring you that will
give you those services and like you'll
be better and the public will be better
off so we we've lost the capacity and
then we've lost the political will and
then the incentives aren't and so like
that you
you now you like walk around and look at
the problem and then like you know
everyone shrugs at it so that there are
some very very deep rooted changes that
will need to take place the problem is
right now our institutions and our
politics don't
have the wherewithal to make those
changes and so everyone just moves
so you're saying the solution is yeah
just breaking the two-party system so an
ideal world
break the two-party system you have a
new party that comes in and says maybe
something along the lines of what i just
said and a bunch of people come together
and be like yeah it makes sense like
there's a middle ground here and then
you you say to folks okay look we're
going to take these people we're going
to bring them to other environments
we're going to evaluate them these
things there's an honest the odd path
for them that doesn't involve just
frankly like jailing them for three
hours then having them out in the street
there has to be some incentive for
uh accountability really because like
some of the horror stories you hear in
new york where someone gets arrested six
times and then the seventh time they do
something heinous and it's in all the
papers and like hey they got arrested
six times already this year i mean that
stuff is real it's happening no one's
held accountable for when they fail i
mean my great fear now is that you have
better leaders you have worse leaders
some of them that are truly terrible or
very destructive some of them that are
great like do some good but it's all
within like a a margin
you know what i mean and during this
period people are just getting more and
more fed up and and they're going to
wind up choosing
the
other like the real strong man or the
fake strong man who acts like a strong
man it's like if you
give me a choice between people who just
like aren't getting [ __ ] done
and are posturing and i just like kind
of play acting and the rest of it or
this person who will get stuff done even
some stuff i don't agree with like
eventually i'll just go this direction
now we're we're at a zone where like the
the strong man i say the faux strong man
because like most of the folks who are
uh uh in this realm are fakes and
phonies
[Laughter]
you know what i mean so in a way they
just give you that feeling yep but
people will choose the feeling i mean
it's one reason why like i look at some
of the races that are going on around
the country i'm
100 confident that republicans gonna win
the house
um and you know i don't know you're not
gonna be 100 confident anything so i'm
like 99.99
99.9
you know our republicans are actually
delivering on stuff like those are
delivering on feelings
at this point more than anything the
problem is that democrats the feelings
that democrats are delivering on are not
great feelings you know it's
like you're like
and in a way i feel for democrats
because it's like oh wow you're like you
know like you have a lot of
problems to solve like you know you
these like you know
institutions that you're responsible for
de facto
because republicans now have just become
the
like tear it down zealots
so they're not like responsible for
anything so the democrats end up being
responsible for the these these
struggles and failures uh but you know
it's just going to be very very hard to
go to voters and energize them around
you know like two or four more years of
institutions that people are turning on
now your point about being able to
decipher yeah going with someone that
you maybe don't agree with fully but
that's going to actually get stuff done
rather than people who just talk it's
going to be way more important over the
next decade i mean we keep seeing the
the merge of
politics always has had an element of
entertainment to it but like more and
more so
with just the conversations going on
social media and everything i don't
think it's crazy when entertainers come
in like i think matthew mcconaughey for
example he genu gives off a genuine
energy about the things that he's
talking about and the actions that he
wants to take and his speech last i
believe it was last week was on point
but there are a lot of like people
within the entertainment realm that are
coming in that are almost like sweet
talkers in a way and they're not
actually going to get stuff done and
we're going to see this increasingly
over the next decade and like two
decades three decades well this is one
of the fundamental problems rules is
like that and this is my fear is that
you could like swap in different people
in that seat
and the the machinery is unable to
deliver
so really the person in the seats is
going to be based on how they make us
feel and so it's like i will now prefer
this sort of feeling it's one reason why
i i'm abolished on matthew mcconaughey
presidential campaign because it's like
look dude's immune from a lot of the
nonsense and people would actually be
interested in hearing him
speak
and the
uh feelings that he emanates or would
would instill in people are like much
much more positive than
the the feelings you're gonna get from
just about any political figure so you
know like people who think that there's
like the real and the performative at
this point our politics has become
so performative and you might as well
just embrace the superior performer the
world has become performative in a lot
of ways yeah yeah
and and this this is one of the the
things i struggle with is that i still
imagine myself to be like a get [ __ ]
done yeah like operator like substantive
human but i'm now trafficking in a realm
where it's like okay to solve the
world's problems we have to
play and we have to fix the politics and
like you can't fix the politics without
uh you know in engaging in like this
political conversation
um pains me
[Laughter]
pains you too maybe but you know like we
gotta do it we gotta we gotta go in and
fix it and rationalize it uh i am really
pumped about the growth of the forward
party over this last number of days and
weeks like we've been growing like crazy
like a beanstalk
and we have some very exciting
announcements coming up um so i'm super
pumped about it but i think one of the
reasons we're growing is because people
are waking up to just how dysfunctional
things are
both sides like oh you know like like so
many people are ready to walk away from
the two-party system um because they
just realize it's it's like you're
getting snowed and bullshitted a lot of
the time uh and things just really are
not working yeah i think again just over
the next decade and beyond having more
conversations about that
those
ties of yes
the feeling that we get from people is
extremely important you know we can
trust our intuitions with how genuine
people are but there's gonna have to be
a lot more conversations about that like
who's actually gonna get stuff done
and the thing we have to push on jules
is like eventually people are going to
turn to the strong man of the fake
strong man it's not going to be good so
you have to figure out it's like okay
who's a positive get stuff done person
and be willing to head in that direction
so so that that that's um the challenge
really yeah one of my friends sent me a
quote recently and it was like um the
most entertaining outcome is like the
most likely today and i'm like that's
actually pretty true a lot of the times
but that's why we need matthew
mcconaughey let our entertainment be
positive instead of just the negative
train wreck yes save us matthew
you